[Musique]
dans l'actualité de ce mardi 5 avril
2016 les sélections en vue des jeux
olympiques sont connus des yvelinois
figure en bonne place pour partir à rio
dans les prochains mois françois pervis
ou encore michael d'almeida le projet
jirau lift porté par le chercheur
lambert traîneau race de l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin pourrait
changer le quotidien des personnes en
situation de handicap son fauteuil
roulant permet de se redresser
explications à suivre la dernière ligne
droite pour le centre commercial parly 2
encore quelques mois de travaux et fin
2017 le chantier de 200 millions d'euros
sera achevée plus des espaces plus dense
n y parler d'eux inauguré en 1969 fait
peau neuve
les sélections pour les épreuves
cyclistes des jeux olympiques 2016 sont
tombés ce lundi 4 avril au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines directeur
technique national vincent jacquet a
dévoilé avec les coachs de bmx devait
était de cyclisme sur route et de piste
les contours de l'équipe de france au
total 24 athlètes ont été retenus sous
réserve de validation du comité
olympique objectif pour ce groupe france
remportée au moins six médailles dont 4
en or aujourd'hui on a des profils dans
toutes les disciplines que ce soit le
bmx soit le vtt que soit la route et la
piste ça peut paraître au demeurant si
on regarde l'ensemble des des profils en
deçà de ce qu'on pourrait annoncer moi
je reste très prudent c'est pas que j'ai
pas confiance en eux mais je suis un peu
superstitieux mais je pense qu'on a
toutes les capacités
affaire six médailles d'une part dont 4
en or et peut-être à lola potentiel il
ya beaucoup de deux chances de médailles
de victoire donc moi c'est un engouement
et c'est très bien pour tout le groupe
france la sélection la plus attendue
était sans aucun doute celle de l'équipe
de france deux pistes les coaches ont
désigné pour le sprint grégory baugé
pistard originaire de maisons laffitte
lenny montrent un françois pervis et le
plaisir ou à michael d'almeida tout
champion du monde ces dernières années
on a fait un choix très motivés par
rapport à des athlètes qui chante
d'exception qui sont présents lors des
grands rendez vous et qui ont cette
marge de manoeuvre qui va s'ouvrir à
nous pendant ces quatre mois de travail
pour aller chercher chercher le graal
olympique ce n'était pas facile on était
cinq pour trois places donc a fallu
faire des choix et j'ai eu
j'ai eu la chance d'être choisis c'est
toujours une grande satisfaction
d'être sélectionné d'être reconnu à sa
juste valeur pour représenter la france
entend plus aujourd'hui olympique sur la
la plus grosse compétition qui soit dans
notre sport les jeux olympiques de rio
se dérouleront du 5 au 21 août les
premières épreuves de cyclisme
débuteront le 6 août au lendemain de la
cérémonie d'ouverture
empathique ou égoïste sur adapté ou
inadaptés bien que paradoxaux ces
exemples sont des caractéristiques
représentatif du fonctionnement de
l'élève intellectuellement précoces une
attitude souvent déconcertante pour les
professeurs confronté à ses enfants le
30 mars dernier la spécialiste jeanne
siaud facchin donnait une conférence à
destination des personnels de
l'éducation des yvelines certains
enfants qui vont être catalogué
d'enfants turbulents
ou d'enfants avec un trouble de
l'attention alors qu'on fait ces enfants
ils ont besoin qu'on les regarde avec
une autre grille de lecture en fête dont
moi ma mission que j'ai accepté c'est de
proposer une grille de lecture pour que
enfin les enseignants puissent ressentir
presque plus dans leur coeur qui sont
ces enfants plutôt que de les penser
avec des idées préconçues
comme ils peuvent là vraiment la tête
favoriser sa prise de position si
l'élève est trop effacé ou lui proposer
un contrat s'il est insolent dès que les
détails et pour agir avec chaque élève
sont donnés par l'association nationale
pour les enfants intellectuellement
précoces répondre à leurs besoins mais
aussi savoir les détecter en créant des
cellules dédiées au sein de certains
établissements
nous nous avons des psychologues
scolaires également qu'ils sont à même
de faire des observations dans les
classes de recueillir des informations
de leurs collègues et de faire en sorte
que le repérage soit fait nous essayons
au niveau départemental à partir d'un
groupe de travail départemental de faire
en sorte que l'ensemble du territoire
yvelinois soit mallet et qu'on ait des
correspondants sur tout le territoire
qui sont à même d'une part d'accompagner
les enseignants mais aussi d'apporter
aux parents une première réponse une
cellule fonctionne déjà à rambouillet
alors qu'une seconde est en train de se
mettre en place à saint quentin en
yvelines pour une couverture totale de
tout le bassin d'éducation yvelinois
d'ici la fin de l'année
ouais on par exemple dans un milieu
professionnel et on a accès à des objets
qui sont à hauteur
donc
comme ça la personne elle est
indépendante c'est un dispositif de
locomotion novateur d'un côté un
fauteuil roulant verticalisateur de
l'autre un gyropode du type segway
l'assemblage de ces deux technologies
donnent giraud lift un dispositif
d'embarquement réduit qui permet de se
déplacer de se verticaliser en même
temps on peut se déplacer aussi bien à
pied que de bol ça c'est la fonction
principale c'était l'objectif principal
mais ont bénéficié des avantages du
gyropode c'est un contrôle de manière
intuitif on se penche en avant pour
avancer on se penche en arrière pour
reculer entrer dans un ascenseur ou
passer par des portes classiques grâce à
sa taille réduite ce fauteuil offre des
capacités de déplacement et de
franchissement extrêmement large avoir
accès à des objets en hauteur pouvoir
être la même hauteur d'une personne
quand on lui parle après il ya tous les
avantages d'être de booster davantage
physiologique donc circulation du sang
réduction des escarres consolidation des
eaux le déplacement du fauteuil se fait
grâce à une petite télécommande ou bien
via son smartphone grâce à une
application dédiée plus d'une année de
travail a été nécessaire pour la
réalisation de ce premier prototype un
travail récompensé puisque giraud leaf a
reçu les prix du jury et du public lors
du concours docteur entrepreneurs des
rencontres universités entreprises 2016
on a d'un point de vue entreprenariale
le juré qui valorise le business plan et
le le projet en tant qu entrepreneuriat
et le public pour le projet là c'est
vraiment plus j'irai physique plus
charnelle de dire vrai c'est quelque
chose qui est qui est important pour ces
personnes là où pour les usagers et donc
ça vraiment ça permet de mettre en avant
le projet et entrepreneurs prochain
objectif pour le docteur traîneau race
la commercialisation de son produit vers
la fin de l'année 2017 pour un prix
d'environ 9000 euros
alors que nous avons encore
dimanche à villiers saint frédéric
de drôles de véhicules dévaler les
pentes c'est ce qu'on appelle des
caisses à savon une course de caisses à
savon ça se passe sur une route en pente
fermée à la circulation et sécuriser et
donc sur lesquels s'élance des véhicules
sans moteur
à
à quatre roues
avec un volant en direction des freins
et tout ce qu'il faut pour la sécurité
simple démonstration ce week end les
participants étaient invités à faire un
baptême de descente mais la course de
caisses à savon est aussi une discipline
sportive sur les compétitions il ya un
chronométrage donc le classement se fait
autant tout simplement c'est chacun sait
lance l'un après l'autre il s'est un
petit peu comment comme en ski alpin par
exemple c'est le même c'est le même
principe ce sport se pratique dès l'âge
de 5 ans il ne reste plus qu'à créer sa
propre voiture et faire jouer son
imagination
vingt mois de travaux pour seize mille
mètres carrés supplémentaires c'est la
dernière étape de transformation de
parly 2 depuis 2010 le centre commercial
sur rénove et s'agrandit débuté en mars
cet ultime évolution va créer une
liaison entre la partie historique du
centre de 1969 et celle de 1987
actuellement séparées par un parking ces
deux parties du donc du centre on veut
mieux les connecter entre elles ont donc
en les reliant par une extension un my
de liaison qui accueillera donc cette
liaison pour le parcours client et en
plus à peu près 16 boutiques 16
enseignes supplémentaires qui se
trouveront donc derrière nous plus de
boutiques mais aussi plus de confort
pour la clientèle dans la configuration
actuelle les clients doivent revenir sur
leurs pas avec ce nouveau bâtiment le
centre formera un carré au lieu d'un
elle aujourd'hui pendant les travaux
1000 places de parking seront supprimés
une douzaine d'agents étaient déployés
pour faciliter la circulation
la première à mesure qu'on sait mettre
en place une politique routière adaptée
dès les abords du centre on oriente les
clients vers les poches de parking qui
sont disponibles ensuite lorsqu'ils
arrivent dans ces nouveaux parkings le
client est orientée avec les hérétiques
piétonne pour lui permettre de rejoindre
notamment le mile gourmet la zone de
monoprix et du bhv qui sont en travaux
dans le centre un kiosque d'information
a été installé pour présenter l'ensemble
du projet aux visiteurs ces travaux là
donner une dimension et une ampleur
encore encore plus intéressante ça lui
donne de l'ampleur ça lui donne un look
un peu plus moderne et moi je trouve ça
très bien coût total des travaux 200
millions d'euros investis en sept ans
fin du chantier pour novembre 2010 est
un cinéma devrait voir le jour à la même
période avec ce coup de jeune le centre
espère attirer plus de 13 millions de
visiteurs en 2018